hi i'm lily rabe and i'm ben affleck
and this is
interview
at black insurance oh there's my
crosstalk
here we go how
is ben affleck
do people google that they said that i
think it's fine nobody's happy he's
doing the wired auto complete interview
how do you expect him to be
how many oscar has been at like that's
not you don't this is modesty prohibits
me too
what are they pretty good best kiss in
armageddon and
best on-screen car chase uh argo and
goodwill hunting how many languages does
ben affleck
oh we think he's sorry
well it's okay
and now i've ripped up the s but you can
figure it out language has ben affleck
peak it peaks at very few uh in fact
none are at their peak but he peaks uh
uh one and
a half three quarters depending on the
day i speak a little bit what's that oh
yes how did ben affleck
wind up in this place in his life and
how did ben affleck and matt damon meet
beth african mate met at the park
playing basketball uh benefit was eight
matt damon was 10 which made him older
and he was at the time taller i know
that's hard to imagine because he's so
small but at the time yeah and we met
and then we played the league together
and we lived two blocks apart and we
were friends and then we went to school
together and uh
there you go there you have it
that's right very exciting what is lily
rabe's
problem
[Laughter]
instagram oh gosh
well it's
rape mama it's just my name it's just my
name lily right yeah just type that in
yeah what is lilly rabe that i mean
that one
tell me tell me what is lilly rabe doing
now oh doing now like what what's she i
assume that's why i'm doing this
no i'm sure it's not okay
what is lily rabe's favorite movie oh
gosh
good will hunting
you hate that movie what was lily rabe
and merchant oh and merchant i like that
they're just merchants casual shoes
well i was portia of course we started
shakespeare in the park and then we
moved to uh
is a lilly rave a revered actor in the
theater
yes look at that is she a spectacular
film actress yes
does ben affleck live in boston i know
the answer uh not not at this time no i
do not live in my mother lives there but
some friends
but i i live in los angeles california
does ben affleck
own
aflac insurance oh like oh this is my
cross to bear imagine this i really
don't want to
it took me a second and now insurance
comes imagine you have a very unusual
kind of
slightly unappealing sounding name
now imagine that somehow there's a huge
insurance company that also has that
name now imagine that insurance company
has a a bottomless budget to buy
television commercials and now imagine
that their
[Music]
creative choice
is to hire a duck to shriek your last
name and as loud and obnoxious away as
humanly possible for the duration of the
television commercial and then imagine
what it's like when you're on an
airplane and the hammered lady behind me
and thinks she's going to do her best
gilbert gottfried for six hours
thank you affleck i don't own it but i
deserve it
i would like a discount does ben affleck
no martial arts dude i mean i don't know
if you count um
i remember i remember matt damon when he
was like 11 told me he had a black belt
in the street fighting
um
but i took i did take a little kung fu
as a youngster for a couple of years and
then the answer is no no the answer is
no yes chris
does ben affleck play poker yes but
nothing likes to play poker and that's
some home games some charity games
the eastern congo initiative has a
charity poker benefit once a year
eastern congo dot org can be found on
the internet where you can participate
and making their lives better for the
people of eastern congo i don't think
there's any reason why that extra money
you have on you that you're gonna like
you know spend on roblox or uh you know
couldn't be used to help someone else
who needs it eastern congo dot org
i'm glad we had this opportunity lily
rave amelia earhart why lily
millie
well i played amelia earhart uh on this
season of american
oh why
why do you ask ryan murphy
because she's a genius that's why why
lily rape taylor swift oh gosh i don't
know i've never played taylor's i love
taylor swift
what is that what is that i mean
it's just like when people think of like
spectacular talented women who enchant
the nation with their gifts
lily babe taylor swift great well i'm
thrilled why lily rabe eileen wernos
again ryan murphy uh yeah i did that on
american horror story how are you
was it good
[Laughter]
why lilly rave heights
i i know well see here's the thing i'm
five eight maybe five eight and a half
but it's great
working with tall actors because there
aren't
a lot of you look at that i got that
going for me and it's really
why ben affleck
i often get that from the actress who
are absolutely lovely normal stature who
who see me and go thank god i'm like oh
this person must be a fan thank god
you're as tall
well you read mine now i'm going to read
yours on this one right okay oh that's
right i i i prefer stages
no i like i like to i love you
so much that i i owed you why is right
[Music]
the best batman
it's a mystery relative to george
clooney i think it's self-evident um but
i'm not willing to say more than that
[Laughter]
why did ben affleck not wear a yankees
hat like at a yankees game no this is a
story that has been exaggerated over the
years in part because of
david fincher's penchant for telling
lies on the in interviews now i was
doing gone girl there was part of the
story where i was supposed to be in
disguise in laguardia airport i think it
was and dave was like yeah you know
you'd like buy a baseball hat at the
thing and then yankees and i said i
can't i'm not gonna wear that hat i'm
gonna put that out of my head because
you know i'll catch fire and uh
and he was like no i was like no i
actually am serious i actually do have
some some principles and uh we had a
brief conversation about it as you do
with your director sometimes when two
people have different creative choices
and we've found a compromise war in new
york mets hat which i thought made this
scene better and i think david thinks so
too i thought but he later on said that
i shut the movie down for four days
which we know isn't honest david we know
we spent those four days shooting
one-eighth of a page
500 tags okay
why do i like ben affleck ugh for so
many reasons whoever is writing in that
question you know i like ben affleck um
because you know i'm stuck with them i
like ben affleck i'm not stick with you
i'm not well no right now i genuinely
like you
yeah why isn't there more ben affleck in
what sense where'd he go
exactly exactly you see that i don't
know why because
bad taste in the directors don't have
vision no um
i
i think there's plenty what is lily rave
the tender bar rattle off that there you
go
no nothing morning to be said do you
know how many imdb credits you have i do
i don't know i only know somebody told
me in a recent interview it just
depressed me
why
there's a big number and i thought you
could only do that by just being very
old that's just not true
that's 42. 42 oh that's um an important
baseball number jackie robinson yeah
what is lilly rabe zodiac sign oh it's i
i'm a cancer with
i know this whole thing
scorpio rising
libra
moon
do you know all three of yours i know
that i'm a leo i think i think there's a
scorpio moon in there i don't know what
it means but i once read that like if
you would read off to like any random
group of people the traits of a zodiac
sign that 9 out of 12 people would raise
their hand and be like that's me
are we really just divided by 12
personality types at random by the month
were born and maybe maybe what
season is lily rabe
in
us
oh in a house
i've done all of them except for one of
them
what lily rape character are you what
lily rape character are you
i am actually the character you play in
the tinderbook
i am that tirelessly dedicated parent
that
beautiful
self-sacrificing parents so full of love
for their children that they
inappropriately foist on them their own
personal needs that they go to yale and
put a sort of unhealthy amount of
pressure on them that's perfect
what is ben affleck's new movie the
tender bar starring lily ray
what is that maplex
duncan order i know this it's a tall
it's a big
it's a big iced one yeah that's right
and it's not see me oh because we're
massachusetts and i was drinking no it's
every day yes of course how do i know
that well i know i just feel like why do
people but of course because i it's
alright it's around it's
observant and you know yes that was a
bad question
okay thank you yeah what movies did ben
affleck produce several yeah
and i produced some of the green light
movies and i produce you know i mean
listen
producing is one of those jobs that's
like you know sometimes people actually
do zero and sometimes people do a great
job like grant husslav with tender bar
uh and grant and george produced argos
so there you go it all full circle
what car does ben affleck
if ben affleck's children are watching
ben affleck only drops away a a car with
a very minuscule carbon footprint
that is very safe
and is very responsible and socially
conscious
which is what is that card because i
need to tell you i should
actually really do
oh you don't have anything i have i only
drive it i got it that's it
thank you for searching and thank you
for watching
[Music]